12:00 TO 3:00 EASTERN AND
JOINING US RIGHT NOW IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST-SELLING
BOOK. IT'S BETTER TO BE FEARED
ABOUT THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS
DYNASTY IN THE PURSUIT OF
GREATNESS. SETH WORKERS FROM
BACK HERE IN THE RICHES THAT
SHOW. HOW ARE YOU?
SETH, GOOD, MAN. HOW ARE YOU?
I'M DOING FINE. SO LET'S GET
FIRST UP ABOUT
WHY YOU THINK BRADY DECIDED
TO FINALLY HANG THEM UP IN
YOUR ESTIMATION.
YEAH, I MEAN, I DON'T THINK
IT'S ONE REASON. I DO THINK
THAT YOU CAN'T OVERLOOK THE
FACT THAT
FOOTBALL IS REALLY HARD
AND HE'S MADE IT LOOK SO EASY
FOR SO LONG
THAT IT'S KIND OF EASY TO TAKE
FOR GRANTED, BUT IT IS REALLY
HARD
TO
PLAY FOOTBALL,
ESPECIALLY ENTERING YOUR 40S
AT A HIGH LEVEL. NOBODY REALLY
KNOWS EXCEPT FOR HIM, WHAT
THAT'S LIKE AND
I THINK THAT HE WAS BEING
HONEST WHEN HE REFERENCED IN
HIS STATEMENT TODAY THAT
YOU KNOW, HE DIDN'T FEEL LIKE
HE COULD GIVE THAT EFFORT,
RIGHT?
AND
BUT I DO THINK THERE ARE SOME
OTHER FACTORS AT PLAY. I MEAN,
HE LOVED THE COACHES IN TAMPA
BAY, BUT HE, YOU KNOW,
WE REFERENCE IT IN A STATEMENT
TODAY THAT HE WOULD DRIVE
BRUCE ARIANS CRAZY. I MEAN,
SOMETIMES THE BOX COACHES
WEREN'T QUITE AS
BUTTON DOT AS THINGS WERE IN
NEW ENGLAND AND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW, THE WAY YOU SAW THE
RAMS ISOLATING COOPER CUP ON A
SAFETY AS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
YOU KNOW,
AND 'RE A TEAM IN TRANSITION
AND THERE.
GOING TO HAVE SOME ROSTER AND
CELERY KEPT HIS SHOES. AND
THEN I THINK THAT
MORE THAN ANYTHING, YOU SAW
HIM. TAKE STEPS THIS PAST
YEAR
TO BE KNOWN AS MORE THAN JUST
TOM BRADY, THE QUARTERBACK AND
REALLY MORE THAN TOM BRADY TO
QUARTERBACK AND
FITNESS GURU. I MEAN YOU SAW
HE LAUNCHED HIS PODCAST WITH
JIM GRAY AND LARRY FITZGERALD.
HE DID MAN IN THE ARENA.
AND THE BRADY BRAND. I THINK
THAT HE THAT
IT REALLY SEEMED TO ENERGIZE
HIM IN A WAY
THAT,
YOU KNOW, FOR THE LONGEST
TIME. I THINK THAT ONLY
IN A WAY THAT, YOU KNOW, FOR
THE LONGEST TIME. I THINK THAT
ONLY FOOTBALL
AND, YOU KNOW, HE SEES A LOT
OF GLOBAL POTENTIAL WITH THAT
ESPECIALLY WITH THE TB 12,
YOU KNOW, PAIRING IT UP WITH
SOME OF THE METHODOLOGIES
OR THAN TV12. ALL THAT SAID.
ED. THIS IS A GIGANTIC HOLE
THAT HE IS LEAVING HIS LIFE.
WHY HE'S ID. THERE'S A REASON
SAID IN THE PAST THAT HE'LL
CONSIDER THERAPY WHEN HE WALKS
AWAY BECAUSE
AS
GISELLE
HAS SAID, FOOTBALL WAS HIS
FIRST
AND
AS WE KNOW WITH, WITH GREAT
ATHLETES, WHEN THEY WALK AWAY.
THE GOLF COURSES AND THE
PRIVATE JETS. AND,
YOU KNOW, THE CUSHY PAID
SPEECHES GET OLD FAST.
YEAH, I KNOW. AND IT'S JUST,
IT'S GONNA BE WEIRD FOR FANS
TO BECAUSE
I THOUGHT HE COULD HAVE KEPT
PLAYING, YOU KNOW, AND,
AND OBVIOUSLY,
HE DIDN'T END IT.
WITH A WIN IN THE SUPER BOWL
AND I ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT,
YOU KNOW, TOM BRADY WOULD
ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY AT HIM.
SELF TO THE LIST OF PEYTON,
MANNING AND
STRAHAN
BETTIS AY AND
RIGHT THAT YOU KNOW,
THAT THAT'S THE WAY THEY
DID IT. YOU KNOW,
RAY RAY LEWIS, RIGHT? I MEAN,
LIKE, THAT'S THE WAY TO DO IT.
AND HE WOULDN'T WANT TO
EVEN WALK INTO THE BOSS
ROOM, ONE DAY KNOWING HE'S GOT
THE EVERY POSSIBLE RECORD
THAT OTHERS HAVE SOMETHING
THAT HE DOESN'T, YOU KNOW,
I
I ALWAYS KIND OF FIGURED BUT
YOU CAN'T CONTROL THAT.
CHEERING EXCEPTION OF
A GOOD LIFE. LAST YEAR, HE
COULD HAVE. YEAH, I THINK HE'S
ALWAYS BEEN A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. LIKE THERE WAS A
MOMENT THAT
I WAS AT HIS I WAS IN THIS
LIVING ROOM AND WE WERE
TALKING AND IT WAS MAYBE
SEVEN YEARS AGO.
IT WAS BEFORE
THE SORT OF
REST OF THE DYNASTY THAT
WHICH NOT ONLY THE PATRIOTS,
BUT REALLY THE TOM BRADY
DYNASTY
WAS  OF
RECOMMENDED AND
HE WAS TELLING ME ABOUT THEY
HAD JUST LOST TO THE RAVENS IN
THE PLAYOFFS AND HE TOLD ME
THAT KURT WARNER HAD SENT HIM
A TEXT
AFTER THE GAME SAYING LIKE
BEING
BEING THE BEST DOES.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU ALWAYS WIN.
IT JUST MEANS YOU WIN MORE
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
AND THAT TEXT REALLY
MEANT A LOT TO HIM BECAUSE IT
WAY THAT VERY FEW ESSENCE IN A
MESSAGES. COULD IT?
YES, IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
WINNING, BUT IT WAS OFTEN IN
FAILURE THAT HE FOUND
SUCCESSES
AND
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE THERE'S
PEOPLE WHO ARGUED HE'D NEVER
LEAVE NEW ENGLAND AFTER
THROWING A PICK SIX ON HIS
FINAL. THROW
AGAINST THE TITANS, AND
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO'D ARGUE,
LOSING TO THE OUT
LOS ANGELES.
IT'S RAMS IN THE PLAYOFFS. BUT
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS
IT. NO, IT WAS MISREAD HIM
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
I THINK THAT WHAT HE
PRIDED HIMSELF ON AS MUCH AS
ANYTHING.
IS THIS KIND OF GENIUS. HE
HAD OF
REFUSING TO CONCEDE ANYONE
ELSE'S IDEA
OF THE INEVITABLE, OR OF
REALITY IN THAT REGARD
ESPN, SENIOR WRITER AND AUTHOR
OF THE,
THE BOOK. IT'S BETTER TO BE
FEARED, SETH WORKERS FROM
RIGHT HERE
ON THE
RICH EYES AND SHOW. WHAT ABOUT
THE WAY IT ALL WENT
DOWN?
FOR RETIRING. THAT WAS WEIRD.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO PUT IT
THAT YOU ASSOCIATE  NOT A WORD
WITH TOM BRADY, WHEN HE CAN
YEAH. L SOMETHING, RIGHT?
YEAH, SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT WAS
WEIRD. I THINK THAT THOSE
CLOSE TO HIM
AND YOU KNOW, PEOPLE INSIDE
THE BOX
STARTED TO SEE THIS COMING,
MAYBE ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF
AGO.
WE DID LIKE A PLAYOFF
PREDICTIONS COLUMN ON ESPN.COM
BEFORE THE PLAYOFFS AND I
PREDICTED THAT BRADY WOULD
RETIRE AFTER THIS YEAR AND
IT WASN'T A REPORT. IT WAS
A PREDICTION BUT
JUST HEARD ENOUGH
THAT,
YOU KNOW,
I THINK THAT ALL OF THE,
THE THE STRAIN FROM THE GAME,
ALL THE OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND
IT WAS JUST STARTING TO
CRYSTALLIZE FOR HIM. AND
REMEMBER WHEN HE LEFT NEW
ENGLAND. HE SIGNED A TWO-YEAR
CONTRACT. I KNOW THAT HE
RENEGOTIATED IN THE
OFF SEASON AND WAS TALKING
ABOUT PLAYING UNTIL HE'S 55,
BUT A LOT OF THAT WAS LIKE
KIND OF FOR SALARY CAP
PURPOSES.
HE SIGNED A TWO-YEAR DEAL, AND
I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE CLOSE TO
HIM. WE'RE ALWAYS KIND OF
DATE. G AT THAT AS AN END
OBVIOUSLY, HE COULD
CHANGE HIS MIND
AT ANY TIME. BUT
SO WHEN HE WHEN WHEN
ADAM SCHEFTER AND JEFF
DARLINGTON A WEEK AGO,
REPORTED THAT HE WAS
NON-COMMITTAL TOWARDS
RETURNING TO THE BOX. I THINK
THAT WAS A HUGE TELL
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE
REPORT OVER THE WEEKEND
FIERCE BLOW BACK, GOT SOME
BUT,
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT HE WAS
ALWAYS GOING TO RETIRE. THEY
ALWAYS KNEW HOW THIS WAS GOING
TO END
ADAM AND JEFF HAD TO WEATHER
THE STORM FOR THEIR REPORTING
TO BE VALIDATED.
AND
IT'S
OBVIOUS GIVEN THAT THE
COMMISSIONER
WEIGHT IN HATE, MADE IN
THAT.
TODAY, THIS MORNING WAS GOING
TO BE THE MORNING THAT HE WAS
GOING TO DO IT
WELL AGAIN,
I NEVER YOU KNOW
DOUBTED JEFF AND
CHAPTERS REPORTING. IT WAS
JUST
DEFINITELY NOT THE MANNER IN
WHICH
HE
SAID, HE WANTED IT OUT THERE.
RIGHT? AND THEN THE QUESTION
IS, IS JUST,
YOU KNOW, EVEN
LAST NIGHT, YOU KNOW, HAVING
DISPOSAL. DCAST AT HIS
AND, AND THEN CHOOSING THIS
MANNER IN WHICH TO DO IT.
DO YOU THINK THIS WAS THE
PLAN LIKE, WHAT WAS THE PLAN
BEST YOU COULD TELL?
DO YOU THINK? I MEAN, I THINK
IT WAS,
YOU KNOW, GIVEN THAT OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE HAD KIND OF COME
OUT AND AND
YOU KNOW CONGRATULATED HIM ON
HIS CAREER
LIKE PEYTON LIKE,
YOU KNOW, ROBERT KRAFT LIKE
ROGER GOODELL, BUT THAT SAID,
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THIS
WAS A MESSY PROCESS, IT REALLY
WAS AND
BUT
YEAH, I'M SURE THAT LIKE EVEN
JEFF AND ADAM REPORTING. IT
HAD TO HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
SURPRISED BY THE YOU KNOW,
JUST HOW STIFF THE BLOWBACK
WAS. I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR A
FACT. I'M JUST GUESSING
YOU KNOW, HERE WE ARE AND YOU
KNOW, HE ENDED UP DOING IT
AND
YOU KNOW, JUST
YOU RUN OUT OF SUPERLATIVES TO
SAY.
AYE, WHEN HE WAS FIRST
STARTING OUT.
IT WAS SOMEONE WHO'S CLOSE TO
ONLY SAYING THAT LIKE HE WANTS
TO HAVE A CAREER, THAT MAKES
YOU FORGET
ANY OTHER QUARTERBACK. AND
YOU KNOW THIS
LIKE THAT'S SUCH A BOLD
STATEMENT THAT I NEVER
FORGOT IT AND AT THE TIME
HE HADN'T EVEN
WON A SECOND SUPER BOWL YET,
YOU KNOW, THIS
WAS AT THE TIME HE LOOKED LIKE
ANOTHER AND A TREND, RIGHT?
LIKE LIKE KURT WARNER
AND JAKE DELHOMME
AND THESE GUYS WHO KIND OF
COME OUT OF NOWHERE AND END UP
HAVING SUCCESS.
HE DIDN'T LOOK LIKE ANYTHING
THAT HE WOULD BECOME
AND I'LL NEVER FORGET. SOMEONE
SAID THAT AND I JUST THINK
IT'S LIKE ALWAYS SPOKE TO HIS
AMBITION. AND HERE WE ARE ALL
THESE YEARS LATER,
TWO DECADES LATER.
AND IT REALLY IS. HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE SO VAST.
AND SO
FAR-REACHING DID IT REALLY IS
KIND
OF. IT MAKES OTHER GUYS
WHO ACCOMPLISHED PHENOMENAL
FEEDS IN THE GAME LOOKS SMALL.
OH, YEAH. I MEAN LIKE FROM NOW
ON YOU GOT TO WIN
FOR TO BE IN THE CONVERSATION,
TO BE ABOVE OU CAN YOU GOT
FORD. WELL, YOU GOT TO BE IN
FOREIGN FOREIGN TERMS OF
CONVERSATION OF BEST, YOU
KNOW
SECOND BEST EVER,
RIGHT? AND THEN AND THEN
YOU'VE GOT A PASS THAT
AND
THEN YOU'VE GOT IT.
WHILE LASTING AS LONG AS HE
DID TO EVEN BE REMOTELY
IN HIS ARENA, TO USE
HIS
PHRASE. LIKE THAT'S IT FROM
NOW ON. AND WHEN WE WERE KIDS
IT WAS LIKE, YOU GOT TO
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
GETTING YOU A BOSTON CANTON,
RIGHT? LIKE NOW
TO IS JUST LIKE 1/4
ONE QUARTER OF THE WAY THERE.
I MEAN, IT'S TOTALLY BEEN
RESET.
YEAH, LAST NIGHT WAS
ANNIVERSARY OF
THE BRONCOS. SUPER BOWL WIN
OVER THE FALCONS. THAT WAS
ALWAYS FINAL GAME, AND HE'S
SCRAMBLING AROUND.
ROUND IN THAT GAME. THROWING
TOUCHDOWNS. AND R
YOU KNOW, HE WALKED AWAY WITH
TWO STRAIGHT, SUPER BOWL WINS
AND FIVE SUPER BOWL
APPEARANCES AND THE WINNINGEST
AND THAT JUST LOOKED LIKE IT
WAS UNTOUCHABLE. HE LOOKED
LIKE HE WAS WALKING AWAY, NOT
BUT HE MAYBE COULD HAVE KEPT
GOING
AND,
YOU KNOW, BRADY ECLIPSE
FIVE SUPER BOWLS A LONG TIME
AGO.
SO
JUST IN THAT RESPECT, THEN
THE
NEXT STEP. DOES HE
DO WHAT?
WHAT ELWAY DO?
DOES HE WANT TO GET IN?
YOU KNOW,
FOOTBALL MANAGEMENT
IS, YOU WANT TO OWN A TEAM,
CLEARLY? IT SEEMS LIKE HE'S
GOT HIS OWN BUSINESSES. THAT'S
WHAT HE WANTS TO DO.
ANYTHING. HE WANTS TO DO IN
MEDIA, ANYONE WILL FALL OVER
THEMSELVES TO GET HIM.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
NEXT
ACT? FINAL FOR HIS NEXT ACT?
YEAH. I MEAN, I THINK THAT FOR
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE, I THINK
HE'S REALLY GOING TO TRY TO
TAKE
HIS BRAND AND THE TV
12 AND THE BRADY BRAND
GLOBAL AND
SEE WHAT THE
POTENTIAL IS WITH.
BUT THAT SAID,
YOU KNOW AND THEY THINK,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CONTENT WITHOUT THE THE GAME
THAT YOU KNOW, REALLY
SUSTAIN THEM AND BROUGHT THEM
SO MUCH JOY
I MEAN REMEMBER RIGHT THOMPSON
WROTE THAT GREAT ARTICLE AND
MICHAEL JORDAN YEARS AGO WERE
JORDANS WATCHING LEBRON JAMES
ON TV AND TALKING ABOUT
HOW HE WOULD DEFEND HIM
KNOWING THAT HE COULD IF HE
JUST
WERE A LITTLE BIT YOUNGER IF
NOT FOR TIME AND
TOM'S GOING TO TUNE IN AND
WATCH
QUARTERBACKS AND KNOW THAT HE
COULD
DO THIS BETTER.
HER. AND
YOU KNOW,
WHEN THAT GOES AWAY, I DON'T
KNOW. I REMEMBER
I WAS WITH ELWAY AND, YOU
KNOW, I TALKED ABOUT IT
AND HE
WAS RIGHT AFTER THEY WON THE
SUPER BOWL
WHEN HE WAS THE GENERAL
MANAGER.
I THINK HE WAS 55 AT THE TIME
AND HE SAID TO ME
FLAT OUT LIKE UP UNTIL A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. I THOUGHT
I COULD STILL PLAY
AND YOU KNOW, THAT, THAT ITCH
THAT COMPULSION THAT DESIRE.
NEVER GOES AWAY
AND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT
BRADY'S LIFE
LOOKS LIKE.
OUT THAT I DON'T THINK HE'S
GOING TO FIND AS MUCH JOY.
TALKING ABOUT THE GAME.
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU EVER BE
RICH ENOUGH TO OWN A TEAM II,
YOU KNOW THAT II DON'T KNOW,
BUT EITHER EVEN. SO
EVEN BEING AN OWNER.
YOU KNOW,
YOU HAVE THE HIGHEST AND THE
LOWS, BUT YOU'RE NOT,
IT'S CLOSED. YOU'RE NOT PART
OF THE TEAM OR NOT IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG
ADJUSTMENT AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT HE'S KNOWN ABOUT FOR A
LONG TIME
TRYING TO PREPARE FOR.
IT'S STILL GOING TO BE HARD
THOUGH. I THINK SO.
LAST 14 YEARS.
YOUR KIND OF WAITED TO FINISH
UP WITH THIS ONE.
AGAIN YOUR BOOK, SETH WORKERS.
FILLED, THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS
DYNASTY IN THE PURSUIT OF
GREATNESS IS JUST ONE OF THE
BEST INSIDE. LOOKS, YOU CAN
HAVE
TWO DATES FOR SURE, ON THE
PATRIOTS. AND THEN FOR ANY
TEAM
IN RECENT MEMORY, SIR,
SO,
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
BRADY LEAVING THE PATRIOTS
OUT OF HIS
CAREER, RETIREMENT STATEMENT?
STATEMENT, YOU KNOW, I DON'T
THINK IT WAS AN ACCIDENT AT
ALL.
I STILL THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME
SOME HARD
FEELINGS OVER THE WAY THAT HE
LEFT IN THE FACT. THEY OPENED
THE DOOR FOR HIM TO LEAVE AND
HE WALKS RIGHT OUT,
A WAY TO ADDRESS HE WILL FIND
HIS FULL CAREER.
PROBABLY PRETTY SOON. YOU
KNOW, WHO KNOWS MAYBE A VIDEO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BUT I
THINK THEY DON'T FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO ADDRESS IT
AND YOU KNOW, MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT,
YOU KNOW, HE WAS A NEW ENGLAND
A LOT OF THOSE MEMORIES. YEAH,
I MEAN,
LET'S BE HONEST. I MEAN THERE
WAS NO UGLIER
EXIT.
BUT
ALL-TIME GREAT FOR A
FRANCHISE AND FRANCHISE THEN
FAVRE AND THE PACKERS. IT
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN UGLIER,
RIGHT? I MEAN
WHERE, WHERE THE SUCCESSOR WAS
DRAFTED AND WAITING AND
ALL THAT. I MEAN, I DON'T NEED
TO READ
RE-LITIGATE IF YOU WILL, BUT
IT WAS UGLY
AND
FARMING AND THE PACKERS ARE
ALL COOL RIGHT NOW, SO
I'M NOT CONCERNED ABOUT ALL
THAT. BUT WHAT WHAT IS IT?
LIKE I THOUGHT
BRADY AND BELICHICK HAD A
CHAT AND A CONFAB AFTER THE
WEEK FOR
GAME.
THAT PUT THIS STUFF
TO BED OR CAME CLOSE. DID IT
NOT
THEN DID
IT? NO, I THINK BRADY IS
ALWAYS GOING TO LOVE
BILL, BELICHICK FOR THE CHANCE
THAT HE GAVE HIM AND HOW
INVESTED HE WASN'T HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW, THE PATRIOTS
MADE AN ORGANIZATIONAL
DECISION THAT THEY DIDN'T
THINK HE COULD PLAY
ANOTHER TWO YEARS. YOU KNOW,
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT YEAR BY
YEAR AT A LOWER,
YOU KNOW, CAP NUMBER
AND YOU KNOW AFTER ALL THAT HE
HAD ACCOMPLISHED.
HE WAS READY TO GO AND
LOOK WHAT HE DID.
I MEAN, HE
THREW FOR OVER 5,000 YARDS,
THIS YEAR. I THINK THAT
INCLUDING THE PLAYOFFS. HE
MUST HAVE COME CLOSE TO 100
TOUCHDOWN PASSES
IN TWO YEARS IN TAMPA.
IT'S JUST PHENOMENAL. HOW
GOOD HE WAS,
HOW GOOD HE IS,
AND
IT'S JUST AS MIND-BOGGLING
AS HIS ENTIRE CAREER
IS, IT'S JUST AS
MIND-BOGGLING, THAT, HE'S
WALKING AWAY
HAVING ACCOMPLISHED,
YOU KNOW, COMING OFF THE
SEASON THAT HE HAD. NO DOUBT
BP, NO DOUBT, BUT I MEAN IN
NOT TO TURN THIS INTO A DEBATE
SHOW, BUT THIS KIND OF HAS AN
INTERESTING
SUBJECT MATTER.
YOU ARE AN EXPERT AT IT FOR
SURE.
I MEAN
EARLIER ON, IN THIS
CONVERSATION. YOU EVEN
SANG PART OF THE CONSIDERATION
OF NO LONGER PLAYING NOW.
IS THE ROSTER AND
THINGS ARE BEING REMADE. I
MEAN, LIKE HE WENT, HE
TURNED
HE TURNED NIKHIL HARRY
INTO
MIKE EVANS, YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN? LIKE THAT. LET'S BE
HONEST. I MEAN PART OF THE
REASON WHY HE'D LEFT NEW
ENGLAND IS BECAUSE IT WAS NOT
A TENABLE SPOT IN WHICH TO WIN
A CHAMPIONSHIP IN 2020,
WHICH HE DID,
YOU KNOW, GRONK WASN'T GOING
TO BE COMING BACK
THROUGH THAT DOOR.
OR IN NEW ENGLAND BUT
DID IN TAMPA. I MEAN, IT ALL
WORKED OUT, YOU KNOW I'M
SAYING SO TO LEAVE NEW ENGLAND
OUT ENTIRELY
FROM A STATEMENT WHERE HE'S
STAFFERS FOR THE BUCS. IT'S
IT'S KIND OF
A HEAD SCRATCHER.
I'LL BE HONEST, UNLESS THERE
UNDERNEATH THIS BRIDGE STILL,
AND YOU'RE SAYING THEY'RE
PRETTY MUCH STILL IS,
I MEAN, I THINK
THAT I THINK THAT THE FACT
THAT HE DID IT, I'D LIKE I
SAID, I JUST, I DON'T THINK IT
WAS AN ACCIDENT.
YOU KNOW, BUT IT'LL BE IT'S
ALSO BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHERE HE LIVES. YOU
KNOW, DOES HE DECIDE?
BUILDING A HOUSE IN MIAMI
AND YOU KNOW, IN A YEAR
THIS HIS OLD FRIEND STEVEN,
ROSS OLD MICHIGAN GUY,
YOU KNOW,
LET HIM KNOW THAT THE DOORS
OPEN JUST IN CASE HE WANTS TO
YOU KNOW, MAKE THAT SHORT
COMMUTE TO THE DOLPHINS
FACILITY.
ALL RIGHT, I BELIEVE THERE IS
A
REAL-TIME UPDATE HERE. SETH
IS JUST A COUPLE MINUTES AGO.
BRADY ON HIS INSTAGRAM
STORY,
KIND OF LIKE
QUOTE SAVED THE
BOB KRAFT
STATEMENT AND THEN
DID A THANK-YOU PATRIOTS AND
PATRIOTS NATION WITH TWO
HEARTS?
THERE YOU GO.
SO IN OTHER WORDS, THE
PATRIOTS ARE NOT
LIKE THE INSTAGRAM STORY, SO
IT'S NOT. SO BASICALLY WE HAVE
WITH THIS IS
A 21ST CENTURY THING.
CERTAINLY FOR A 44 YEAR OLD
MAN IS RETIRED.
HAS RETIRED THE HAHNEMANN. SO
BASICALLY
THE
PATRIOTS ARE NOT
INSTAGRAM FEED WORTHY, RIGHT?
BUT INSTAGRAMS
INSTAGRAM STORIES ARE
ARE
SHAREABLE IN THE
THE FEED
IS NOT RIGHT.
SO WHERE DO WE LIKE, DO WE
DO? IT'S DOES A TICK, TOCK
BREAK THE TIE OR WHAT
DOES THAT IS? IT JUST ALSO
THINKING ABOUT THE EFFORT TOM
HAD TO GO TO, HE WOULD HAVE
TO SCREENSHOT THE PATRIOTS
STATEMENT, THEN PUT IT INTO A
STORY AND THEN TYPE OUT SOME
TEXT. I MEAN A LOT OF EFFORTS
THERE, SETH, THIS IS FOR THE
PAPERBACK. I THINK THERE YOU
GO.
I MEAN, I'M REALLY THANK YOU.
GO DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE AND
THIS ONE.
IN THIS ONE, BUT LITERALLY
LIKE THAT'S WHAT I
LEAPT OUT AT ME AND THEN THE
FACT THAT THE WORD RETIREMENT
WASN'T IN THERE EITHER. IT'S
JUST LIKE, YOU KNOW, I'M GOING
TO F----- YOU TO FATHER, TOM.
I'M NOT GONNA EVEN USE THAT
WORD
IN MY WALK AWAY
STATEMENT. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING? LIKE, I DUG THAT ONE,
TO THAT ONE
WAS CAUGHT, I CAUGHT MY EYE ON
THAT. SETH. THANKS FOR THE
TIME, MAN. ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE TO SENSE THAT
YOU AND
THAT YOU ARE WILLING TO
PROVIDE HERE. THANKS AGAIN.
MY PLEASURE,
MA'AM. THANK YOU, BETTER. TAKE
CARE, SETH WORKERS
FROM, I FOLLOW HIM ON TWITTER,
YOU SHOOT AS WELL AT SETH
WORKERS
HIM ON INSTAGRAM. I MEAN,
WE'RE ALL BOOKS, ARE SOLD.
WHAT A GREAT BOOK. THIS IS
YES, EVERYTHING INSIDE
RIGHTS. YOU MUST READ. OKAY.
SO
RIGHT HERE ON THE RICH EISEN